veamos otras dos reacciones de algunos y
empezaremos con la alucinación de
algunos así que el peso con mi alquilo
de aquí y añado a mi alquiló un
equivalente más de halógeno tengo x2
disolventes será tetracloruro de carbono
y añadiré estos dos átomos de halógeno a
través de mi triple enlace en una
adición ante por lo que esos dos
halógenos terminaron en lados opuestos
uno del otro
esta es una adición
en ti
de mis halógenos así ahora podría añadir
dos equivalentes de mi halógeno y si eso
sucede cada uno de estos carbonos
terminará con dos enlaces halógenos así
en mi producto
ahora el mecanismo de la alojen acción
de alki nos no se ha entendido
completamente y debido a eso solo
mostraremos un ejemplo práctico en lugar
de ver el mecanismo veamos un alc y lo
continuaremos dibujando un al 'chino'
por aquí aquí tengo a mi carbono con un
triple enlace a otro carbono pondré un
grupo metilo en un lado aquí escribamos
ch3 aquí y pondré un grupo de tilo en
este lado tengo ch2 ch3
entonces a ese aquí no añadiré bromo y
utilizaré tetracloruro de carbono como
mi solvente y diré que un equivalente
más de mi bromo es añadido cuando haces
tu este geometría tendrá solo un
equivalente más así así que añadiré mis
dos promos anti uno del otro cierto
continuamos mostrando mi enlace triple
convirtiéndose en un enlace doble y mis
dos bromo se añadirán ante uno del otro
se añadirán en lados opuestos de mi
doble enlace así y aún tengo un grupo
metilo por aquí enlazado al carbono en
la izquierda y continuaré poniendo mi
grupo metilo así
y el carbono en la derecha aún tiene un
grupo de tilo unido a él sh2 ch3 este
sería el resultado de la alojen acción
de éste al 'chino' veamos una reacción
más de alc y nos veamos la ozono lisis
lado solo lisis de alc y nos déjame
continuar escribiendo o show
no lisis por aquí
y hemos visto esta reacción antes una
reacción similar cuando hicimos esto con
al menos esta vez lo haremos con alc y
nos veamos un alc y no
aquí hay un alquilo diré que es un
alquilo interno lo que significa que el
enlace triple se encuentra en el
interior de la molécula no está en el
final de la molécula veamos la ozono
lisis de alc y los internos primero y
cuando estás haciendo los análisis estás
añadiendo ozono a la molécula en el
primer paso
vimos un mecanismo muy muy detallado de
la oso noleysis de al que nos puede
regresar y ver este vídeo en este vídeo
no veremos ningún tipo de mecanismo sólo
veremos los productos así que añadimos
ozono en el primer paso y en el segundo
añadiremos agua
y lo que eso hace es que esto es in the
two triple enlace y te da ácidos
carboxílicos como tus productos
dos de ellos continuamos dibujando esos
dos ácidos carboxílicos y luego
trataremos de indicar de dónde viene
todo aquí está uno de los ácidos
carboxílicos y luego aquí estará el
ácido carboxílicos que acabará en el
lado derecho así que haré esta er prima
por aquí así que continuemos e
identifiquemos los carbonos mostremos
que el carbono de aquí está unido a un
grupo r ese es este carbono unido a un
grupo r y luego aquí en la derecha este
carbono es el que está unido a la r
prima cierto este carbono es el que está
unido a la r prima
-sin diste tu enlace triple cierto
rompiste tu triple enlace y crearás dos
moléculas separadas de esto obtienes
ácidos carboxílicos de esta reacción
ahora veamos la ozono lisis de algunos
terminales en lugar de que el triple
enlace esté en el interior de la
molécula ahora el triple enlace está en
el final de la molécula eso hace a esto
un hidrógeno justo aquí añadamos
nuevamente o solo
el primer paso y agua
mi segundo paso
y en el lado izquierdo el lado izquierdo
nos dará el mismo producto que antes
cierto continuamos identificando eso en
azul este carbono y este grupo r vimos
antes que eso nos dará un ácido
carboxílicos así continuamos dibujando
eso otra vez es lo mismo esta porción de
la molécula nos da el mismo producto que
antes obtenemos un ácido carboxílicos y
nuevamente los carbonos este es el
carbono en azul
grupo r en azul esos son los mismos del
lado izquierdo de tu reacción ahora en
el lado derecho de mi reacción en el
lado derecho de la reacción la porción
del alquiló terminal
de hecho obtendrás dióxido de carbono
ahora solo tienes un carbono en qué
pensar este es el único carbono que
tienes aquí obtendrá co2 de esto
continuamos dibujando
co2 como tu producto así recuerda que es
una molécula lineal y esta reacción fue
usada hace décadas para la determinación
de estructura cierto
si estuviera presente un al 'chino'
terminal y lo hiciera reaccionar con
ozono entonces obtendrías algo de
dióxido de carbono y podrías también
analizar la molécula a través de los
ácidos carboxílicos que obtuviste por
ejemplo podrías ver cuántos carbonos
están en tu grupo r y luego eso te daría
una idea de la estructura y de todo ese
tipo de cosas esto solía ser una
reacción muy importante en química
orgánica ahora con todo lo relacionado a
la espectroscopia que tiene la química
orgánica está reacción ya no se utiliza
tanto veamos un ejemplo de una reacción
de ozono lisis veamos esta de aquí
tomaremos ese alquilo terminal le
añadiremos ozono en el primer paso y
luego le añadiremos agua en el segundo
paso y veamos con cuántos carbonos
estamos lidiando aquí algunas veces eso
es lo que confunde a los estudiantes
cierto hay un carbono dos carbonos
3 carbonos y en este lado está nuestro
cuarto carbono y ese carbono en el
extremo derecho está unido a un
hidrógeno haciendo eso un al 'chino'
terminal así que tengo 4 carbonos de los
cuales preocuparme y cuando se somete a
una decisión de alki no romperá la
molécula de aquí romperá ese triple
enlace y entonces obtendrás dos
productos obtendrás un producto con tres
carbono cierto aquí en la izquierda y
luego un producto con un carbono en la
derecha el producto con tres carbonos en
la izquierda será un ácido carboxílicos
lo único que debes hacer es dibujar un
ácido carboxílicos de 3 carbonos
continuamos haciendo eso aquí está
nuestro ácidos carboxílicos
3 carbonos ese es sólo uno de nuestros
productos y los talquinos terminales nos
darán co2 el cual se encarga del otro
carbono aquí en la derecha obtendremos
o dos como el otro producto de esta
reacción eso resume todas nuestras
reacciones de alc y nos en el siguiente
vídeo veremos algunos problemas de
síntesis usando todo lo que hemos
aprendido en el primer semestre de
química orgánica especialmente
incluyendo algunas de las reacciones de
algunos